I'm Molly Webster. This is gonads episode for this week.
We're releasing two episodes that are related starting with
hello [inaudible] bully. Now I said the TG gas. Yeah,
I take it [inaudible] Radiolab say duty Chan is a world class runner from India.
Made us had Molly B TV. Hello, do you t? Hi, how are you?
Kinky. Have you had it? I called her with more perfect producers. Sar Cari,
I was having Sarra translate duty speaks Hindi. [inaudible].
We caught up with her and hydro bod where she's currently training and I called
her because a few years ago, right as her career was taking off,
she got caught up in this maelstrom that almost ended it and throughout the
series we've been asking all these questions about biological sex inside the
body and this moment in her life takes all of those questions and thrusts them
out into the world in a very public way.
Casing. Just to start at the beginning, I've gotten better though. In p
made a joke. Go, hey duck.
I'm from a village in Arissa called Chicago Board. How many?
There are nine people in my family. Six sisters.
One brother and my parents, they [inaudible].
My oldest sister is the one who got me into running when I was five years old.
Duty sister was a track star in school. Okay.
They made a wag board and [inaudible] and as I got older she started training
me, Brownlee club og Nikki. There was no track to run on,
so I would run along the edge of the river or on the road or in the village,
what? Our family was poor and we couldn't afford shoes,
so I would run barefoot and the tiny pebbles in the road would get stuck in my
feet. My sister pushed me.
She didn't let me slack off when I would complain or not want to train.
Years went on.
She kept training with her sister and she just got faster and faster and faster
until 2012 she had this big break.
I'm trying to think of how old she was then.
I think she was 16 this is a journalist who has spoken to and written about
duty,
Ruth [inaudible] contributing writer at the New York Times magazine and Ruth
says,
what happens in 2012 is do t qualifies for the National Youth Championships in
Bangalore and she wins the a hundred meters in 11.8 seconds.
[inaudible] and usually Indian female runners are running that same race in 12.2
or 12.3 seconds like grown up professional runners while she's still a teenager.
And then the next year she goes back to the youth national champion.
Chips wins gold in a hundred meters and the 200 meters that same year,
still 2013 failure.
[inaudible] duty starts racing internationally.
Why did you jump into the World Youth Championship?
She ran her best hundred meter time yet this job that they do like number two
but that'd be live with one
11.62 only about a second slower than the world record.
And in June, 2014
she wins gold again at the Asian championship in Taipei, medic, Boise
[inaudible]. My coach and my family started saying to me,
duty, you're going to go to the Olympics.
So duty is basically the hottest young female runner in India.
And then 2014 was preparing for the Commonwealth Games.
Richard sort of like a warm up to the Olympics for certain countries.
And as she's preparing for the Games, um,
she gets sent to the team doctors for doping test and she said like,
this was kind of a normal part of her life, but
I had blood tests done ever since I was little.
We did take a dope test a month before every tournament and also after the race.
So she goes to see the team doctor and he's like, no blood,
we're going to do an ultrasound. Huh? Which is not normal.
And so she asked them why and they just said, oh,
we're like looking at your bone density. And so she's like, okay, whatever.
Eventually she does do a normal blood test, uh, goes back,
keeps training for the Games. A couple of weeks later,
picks up the newspaper and sees her picture on the front page of the newspaper.
[inaudible].
There was a picture of me with a huge headline screaming dude,
the disqualified from the
team,
Mitchell [inaudible] followed by the new story that said that [inaudible] I was
a male, not a female, she has no idea what's going on.
But she said at that point, her phone starts blowing up when a number did best.
That was a bad call.
The media called me and told me all the details like there was this gender test
that happened saying, is it true? Is it true you failed a gender
test? No hybrids. [inaudible]
there was this hyperandrogenism test, this gender test,
and the results said that I wasn't a woman, that I was a man. I
like [inaudible] and couldn't compete with the women, but men soon,
good pride and ob, I was shocked.
I didn't understand how this could happen again.
And the media kept asking me, what are you actually, yeah, and I said,
I don't know.
My parents gave birth to me and I grew up the way that they raised me.
The Miller King. I'm a girl,
I'm a woman and I didn't know about anything that was being reported about me.
[inaudible]
do you feel that gender test,
is that what was happening in the MRIs and the ultrasounds? Yeah.
What exactly is a gender test like what is that exactly? I, yeah,
I didn't I that he duty saying it was the first time I'd ever heard that phrase,
but it's actually this thing that's been happening in sports for a long time and
I'm going to take you on a journey back to the beginning of it.
[inaudible]
so I didn't know this but the,
but the sort of first modern day Olympics was 1896 which seemed very recent.
The reason, and there were no female athletes really and apparently like the,
the one of the people who is charged with sort of like restarting the Olympics
said something like this is like no place for women. But sure enough,
by 1900
I made great controversy.
It was decided to allow women to compete for the first time
you had 22 female athletes,
which is,
would express that athletic competition could physically damage the Lucas sex
was not uncontroversial,
but by the 19, by 1960, yeah.
Wrote welcomes the summer games of the 17th Olympia,
which were the Olympics in Rome. There were 600 female athletes.
And so two things complained at the same time,
which is a lot of women now participating in the Olympics.
[inaudible] the Cold War, you know, the Soviet Union,
the u s a lot of posturing. Yeah.
And there was this like fear not very merited.
It turns out that maybe the Soviets were taking men and putting them into female
athletics to win more metals or that the US was doing that also. Huh.
And so what started were these things that everyone calls
the nude parade?
Oh,
what is that?
So women would line up wearing bras and panties and they would go in front of
three doctors, often men. Um,
and they had to lower their underpants. And Are you serious?
Yes. And they were examined palpated and measured.
And this makes me very uncomfortable. Yeah, so invasive.
So invasive. Invasive is the first word that comes to mind.
So this is happening all throughout the city.
People start to complain rightly
and the IWF,
which is the International Association of Athletics Federations and the
International Olympic Committee both come under criticism.
And so
in the late 1960s they come up with another approach
[inaudible]
another test. Okay. And that's a chromosome test. Okay.
I have to call the bar body test. Great. From the inside of the cheek,
a placed under a microscope and then tested for x's and y's dog spot showed up
only on female cats. So anybody who has x,
x is okay cause that's supposedly equals female.
And anybody who has something other than x, x is suspect.
If they find a y chromosome in there, that means you your male.
Here you have a test that's theoretically less invasive.
People don't have to pull down their underwear and way more precise.
The idea at that point was, well,
IOC in 1968 said that the chromosome test quote indicates quite definitively the
sex of a person,
except when it doesn't.
Like we talked about in our last episode,
there is a gene on the y chromosome that if you have it, and if it turns on,
you will likely become a male. But there are a lot of x,
y women in the world. These are women who had a y chromosome,
which is associated with male, but that little gene, it didn't turn on.
Conversely, you can have x, x males,
meaning that little piece of the y chromosome got onto an x.
There are all of these different chromosomes like aberrations.
You could be x, x, x, x,
you have two extra xs and you could have three extra xs as a woman,
as a female. Yeah Huh? You could be x, x, y, you can be x,
y, y, and these are perfectly healthy people. It runs the gamut.
You could have a fertility issues or developmental issues or no issues at all.
And so the debate was, you know,
there were a lot of geneticists and endocrinologist who are saying sex isn't
determined just by chromosomes.
It's determined by hormones and by physiology and you know,
totally getting away from gender, which is even more complicated.
But just because you don't have x, x doesn't mean that you aren't
a woman.
And eventually all of the sports governing bodies came around to that
conclusion. And by 2000 everybody was like no more chromosome testing.
In fact,
the World Federation that governs track and field has voted to scrap all testing
for gender. You have this moment where,
mm,
it looks like gender testing is gonna go away. Cold War is over,
those fears are gone. Maybe we didn't need it anymore.
But then this other idea walked into the room that actually been there all along
this idea of fairness
because the fact of the matter is if you compare male athletes to female
athletes and pretty much every track and field event, except for a few,
here's a big difference in performance.
[inaudible] marina paint drywall,
like take the 800 meters
gone.
The women's record is one minute 53 28 whereas the men, yeah,
hello [inaudible]
almost 13 seconds faster. In fact, I talked to a,
I talked to on background to one female athlete world champion, uh,
one of the fastest woman in the world and she said her fastest mile is regularly
beaten by like a good high school boy.
And so if you're a female athlete or even like a spectator who's watching this
sport, you want to make sure that females and males aren't racing each other.
And so what you saw, um,
when this sort of like organized gender testing went away is that whenever
someone got really, really fast, uh, whenever a female got really fast,
there was finger pointing.
Okay.
And this all came to a head in 2009.
So now we go down to trackside off all that excitement as the women try and
gather themselves for the 800 meters fine.
19th of that year, a South African runner, just 18 caster Semenya
[inaudible] Jessica crushes the field.
[inaudible] is on again and she's great. Cyber showed up, cheese
on the final lap she wins by is so much
well that smashes the world list what, almost two seconds.
And almost immediately after the race, my conclusion was, okay,
something isn't a, something's going on here. There was something not right.
There was just a thought that there was a problem. Oh yeah. Yep.
This is Madeline pape,
my phd candidate in sociology and an Olympian for Australia.
She ran against caster Semenya and that heat is,
she's since become a big defender of caster. But she says at the time,
because the menus times were increasing so quickly because she was kicking the
fields ass like so totally.
People around me were talking about her spreading rumors and spreading.
And what were the people around you saying? Oh um, is she a man? Look,
she just looks like a man cause she's a tomboy. It wasn't that I was like,
I didn't hold a strong opinion about it. I just was like,
I just want the IWF to, to deal with it and make it go away.
And so you had gotten to the point where you were opposed to caster competing.
Oh,
I was opposed to Casta competing almost immediately at in Berlin
[inaudible]
over the next 24 hours.
She says the rumors got louder and louder basically like a cacophonous.
Well, there was a very dramatic race in Berlin last night,
but the drama had to do less with
who won the race then who was in it and whether they should have been there.
There was discussion happening in the media.
The big question this morning is whether one of the runners should be in the
men's or women's race. She runs like a man, talks like a man. Is she a man?
Is the new world champion of the Women's 800 meter race? Really a woman at all.
When I'm pacing up, that's when the IWF the sport,
the governing body,
the IWF claimed that they had no choice but to announce something at that point
that yes,
they were going to investigate Cassius ammonia because they had concerns about
her sexual development.
If at the end of this investigation it is proven that the athlete is not a
female,
we will reserve hall her name for the results of the competition today.
It was one of those things I think where looking back I feel like,
um, it makes me sad. Yeah. It really makes me sad.
What ended up happening to catch us the menu?
Well, the was banned her,
there were all these closed door meetings and she didn't raise for like a year.
What the IWF testing revealed about some menus.
Physiological makeup never has been confirmed actually,
but what emerged from all the Michigan is that in the end,
the eye devil AAF recommitted to gender testing,
trying to figure out some clear bright,
measurable way to draw a line between male and female.
We choose to have two classifications for our competitions,
men's events and women's events.
This means we need to be clear about the competition criteria for those two
categories
and the way they decided now to be clear was no longer about chromosomes,
no more medieval nude parades. Instead,
they were going to look at hormones, specifically
testosterone,
testosterone either naturally occurring or artificially inserted into the body
provides significant performance advantages.
I think there is little question about that.
The idea was we know that testosterone causes muscles that are like faster,
stronger, leaner, and that men have 10 to 30 times more testosterone than women,
which is a byproduct of having testes.
And so the concern was in these women that have that, uh, y gene,
um, either that they might have internal testes that haven't descended or like a
gonadal streak,
like some reproductive tissue that would be emitting testosterone,
giving them some sort of male like advantage.
And so in 2011, the um,
the IWF decides that they will institute a test for high testosterone levels.
And so if the testosterone levels falls
with within the male range, um, then they're to be barred.
And this is the first time they try and put a number on it.
They say that your testosterone levels,
if they're greater than 10 nanomoles per liter,
you cannot run animals pretty. I know. What does that even mean?
So this rule gets put into place. Um,
and this is the rule that do bumps into and ultimately pushes back against that
part of the story. After the break,
I'm Kelly Ross calling from King George Virginia. Radiolab presents.
Gonads is supported in part by science sandbox assignments foundation initiative
dedicated to engaging everyone with the process of science.
Additional support for radio lab is provided by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation.
When the legendary rapper prodigy died after being hospitalized for sickle cell
anemia last year. His friends, his fans were shocked in the summer. Tony,
like you talking about this sunny day right here, that we have it right now,
man, making bs. Prodigy is dead right now.
I'm Mary Harris and I'm Christopher Johnson.
The realness is a new podcast from w NYC studios that takes you inside prodigies
music and asks why he couldn't escape a single recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness wherever you get your podcasts
really fast. We're back. I'm Molly Webster.
This is gonads episode four with Indian runner.
Do Ti chop gold at the,
so when do ti shows up in 2014 when they take her in for a secret gender test
because she's doing so well. It is to test for high testosterone.
Lennix Federation of India, the cited, she did not count as a woman.
Her natural testosterone levels were too high and so
do t gets banned.
I was just calling five, three days before the Commonwealth Games,
one of the games and I was told that I couldn't participate because of
hyperandrogenism.
Had you ever even heard about like the idea that women could have high
testosterone or something called Hyper Androgen Ism?
[inaudible] hyperandrogenism give out. Admit.
So not talk about it man.
No, I didn't know anything about it. We'll blame what Judy's first thought was.
Basically, this is bullshit.
My family and my friends and my fans kept saying to me,
you must be the victim of some kind of politics.
You were running so well and that's why someone's trying to stop you.
So she gets her own doctor and she does the tests again.
Well, she does the results in this test where the same
and I started to believe that there was something wrong with my body.
[inaudible]
she told me that she cried for days.
The data [inaudible]
it's not as mostly scared because I didn't know anything about it.
She said, I felt naked. I am a human being, but I felt like I was an animal.
I wondered how I would live with so much humiliation.
[inaudible] in our village,
children are born at home and no one goes to the hospital to deliver babies.
Had I been born at the hospital,
maybe the doctor would have said what was going on inside my body and I would
have probably understood this better as a child, like a named method,
but that wasn't the case.
I was born at home and raised like a girl and there were no issues surrounding
that though ligand
[inaudible] and when suddenly the question was raised about my gender,
calling me a male [inaudible] it was very confusing.
Give me a [inaudible]. How could I have just become a man one day?
Ultimately duty decides I'm going to fight this and Ruth says she sends a letter
appealing her band to the Athletics Federation of India.
She writes, I was born a woman, reared up as a woman.
I identify as a woman and I believe I should be allowed to compete with other
women,
many of whom are either taller than me or come from more privileged backgrounds,
things that most certainly give them an edge over me.
And eventually duty ends up at the, uh, court of Arbitration for [inaudible]
[inaudible] is that a higher bodies and the I a a s it's like the,
it's like the Supreme Court of Sport. Wow. Everyone calls a cas.
So on the one side you have duty and on the other side you have the I a f I AA
African [inaudible] track and field around the world.
Sort of the way it breaks down is duties essentially making two main arguments.
The first is that the hyperandrogenism rule is discriminatory,
discriminatory towards women, to which the IWF essentially says,
yeah, it kind of is,
but we're doing it for a reason and that reason outweighs the risk.
Right. Definitely. There's definitely an argument that if you eradicated gender,
um, you would be screwing over hundreds of thousands of women. They're sort of,
their big thing is like, listen, as a society, even in this court case,
we all seem to agree we want to separate men and women.
We need to figure out some way to do this. Do Tease response to that.
Her second argument is, sure, okay fine, we need you to separate the sexist,
but the way you've chosen to do it is not solid.
You have this number 10 nanomoles per liter,
which is supposedly the high end of testosterone for women.
But if you actually look at the data, there's crazy variability.
Like you will see women with levels that were like less than one and the levels
that were above 30, um, which is typically thirties,
like considered high for men. So there was this, the,
the studies that came out where one study was like, um,
we've, we've looked at all these different testosterone levels and you know,
there's an average for men and there's an average for women and they're on
different ends of a spectrum. But what we saw is there's totally overlap.
It's not like one end, the other end, never. The two shall meet that.
Like there's that, that some women go high and some men go low and you've got,
you know,
men with low testosterone who are world-class champions and you've got women
with high testosterone that never win. It's just,
it's not always clear the role that testosterone has in performance. Oh really?
I thought it would.
I thought that was well established that if the testosterone will make you
faster and then what steroids do, well,
th there's agreement that's synthetic testosterone,
steroids ramps up performance helping both men,
male and female athletes jump higher and run faster.
But there's vehement disagreement about whether natural testosterone,
one's own testosterone has that same effect. Why, why wouldn't it?
Well, that's a really good question. Um,
the IWF witnesses argue that logic suggests that natural testosterone is likely
to work the way synthetic testosterone does.
But some scientists argue that a sudden burst of testosterone is much different
than sort of a natural level of testosterone that your body's calibrated to the
long and the short, the science is surprisingly contested. Furthermore,
duty argued, if you really want to talk about fairness,
you need to look beyond sex. There are all sorts of advantages that people have.
You know,
some people are born with increased aerobic capacity and others with resistance
to fatigue or super long limbs or flexible joints are large hands and feet and
other people have disadvantages. Like Dooty said,
I came from a village and in southeast India where I raced for years with no
shoes and only had vegetables and rice.
You know like if you want things to be fair then like we should all have the
exact same upbringing, the exact same coaching system,
the exact same shoes. But the IWF say,
well that's on about the division between men and women.
If sports is divided by men and women,
we need to find out what the thing is that divides men and women.
July,
2015 the court of Arbitration for sport rule today that duty Chandi could
continue to race despite are higher than normal levels of testosterone court
rules.
That duty can continue to race and they say to the IWF like,
you don't have enough scientific evidence to have this hyperandrogenism rule.
Go work on that.
Let us know what you find and
[inaudible] through whole controversy. At least a year goes by.
Duty never stops running and he made it,
cause my coach told me no matter what, just keep training,
the bond was all day.
I wake up at 5:00 AM trained from six to 10 moto gloss in and then we hit the
grounds again from four to six for the third round of training with the coach.
And the summer after the ruling at a big international meet in Kazakhstan
duty ran 11.3 in the hundred meter
setting,
an Indian national record and she makes the Olympics India's duty.
Jon has scripted history becoming the first ever Indian woman to qualify for the
three Olympics in the hundred meters event since 1980
meanwhile the IWF just like the court asked,
they go back to the drawing board and they commission their own study and last
summer it was published
[inaudible].
What they did was analyze blood samples from a couple thousand athletes at the
2011 and 2013 world championships.
And what they were looking for was to see if the women with high testosterone
outperformed the women with low testosterone
[inaudible].
And what they found is that if you are a female runner who runs the 400 meter,
the 800 meter, the 400 hurdles are the mile,
you are conferred an advantage with high testosterone levels in only those
events and only those events. Oh.
And there's also a throwing event in one other. Um,
having high testosterone levels conferred an advantage of like 1.8% to four and
a half percent faster, or like 2% to 4% roughly.
And just to say like if you're a runner,
1% could be like two tenths of a second,
one 10th of a second, which is, which is often how races are designed. Right?
And these, so these, these distances are the higher distances.
Am I right to these distances of the middle distance idol distances? Yeah.
So the sprint,
not the sprints and not the long with their study finds is that the sprints do
not, you do not get an advantage from testosterone. The long distance.
No advantage from testosterone. These middle distant races,
seemingly an advantage from testosterone and a throwing event with a hammer
throw what a fucking mess.
So you're saying to me that like we started with like the nude parade and now
where we end up with like the line that we've chosen to draw is in these middle
distance races.
That's where we're going to like make a big deal about trying to separate out
the sexism. Yes. Like it feels just,
it feels like everyone's just arguing over change at this point.
Even since that study was published,
the data's been called into question and there's a call for retraction and they
publish it. There's a bunch of data errors.
The authors still stand behind the study and in fact the IWF is now using it as
the basis for a new testosterone rule. They introduced this past April.
We reached down to the IWF a few times, didn't hear back,
but I mean, right now we're arguing about testosterone,
but I think that the bigger issue here is that we're like coming into a moment
as society where we're more and more open to gender fluidity,
but if we've all agreed on a whole that, that it,
that it's unfair to group women with men in sports,
then we do have to answer a real question,
which is how do I keep the dichotomy,
the binary in athletics,
while the rest of the world is changing and what you see with duty or any of
these female athletes is they're sort of caught at the place where these two
worlds meet. Those sort of things,
which is a hard place to find yourself. TMZ
Duty told me when this whole thing blew up, she was only 18 years old.
I was at this age when boys and girls start falling for each other,
and there was a guy who fell hard for me and I fell for him too.
We used to talk a lot on the phone and thought that one day when we got older
we'd get married.
But when the news in 2014 started appearing every layer,
he started asking me who I was for real.
He said, if you're a boy,
then how can the two of us both boys stay together in the future?
How will our dreams of having children or creating a family ever come true?
Eventually I did tell him that the results confirmed that I had hyperandrogenism
and I asked him, are you going to love me and marry me or not?
He said, no,
I don't love you anymore and I can't marry you because my family doesn't approve
of our relationship I to kick it. So I said, fine.
So he forgot me and I forgot him too.
After that guy left me, there haven't been any other guys that like me anymore,
but now a lot of girls have started liking me and a lot of them say that they
want to settle down with me. How do you feel about that?
Guess I'll look that up. Cool.
I guess I feel happy and sad. My childhood dreams of having a husband,
creating a family with him might not come true.
But when I see all these girls still attracted to me, I often
wonder if I could make a home with a girl named [inaudible] in India.
Only boys and girls get married. Girls don't marry girls.
If it was more acceptable to marry a girl in India,
do you think you'd want to do that?
Right now I haven't thought about it and I'm focusing on my sports career,
but after I'm done with my career,
I am going to need someone to spend my life with. Right. They'll dictate.
So I'll see if there is any guy that likes me,
I would marry him and settle down.
But if there aren't any guys interested in me and girls still like me,
then I would settle down with a girl. Whoever likes me. Right.
It won't give me any like I would spend my life with them.
[inaudible]
three weeks ago,
Duty Chon made headlines by breaking her own national record in the 100 meter.
She beat it by 100th of a second.
Sure.
[inaudible].
This episode is reported by me,
Molly Webster with co reporting and translation by Sar Carte.
It was produced by Pat Walters with production help from Jad Abumrad and Rachel
Q. Sick. The gonads theme was written, performed,
and produced by major Connery and Alex Overington.
Special thanks to hit your mark my on
Sudei Andrea Dunaif or QT ry and pay Ashley Mitra plus.
Thanks to Joe Osmund CSUN and Madeline Pape,
who's currently working on research about the regulation of female transgender
and Intersex athletes in sport. I'm Molly Webster. See you next week.